how to deal with copycats as you get
successful with your company you're
gonna have people who will rip you off
who will copy everything that you do and
try to put it word for word on what
they're doing to try to copy your
success it's never going to work
and you can either spend your time
chasing these guys down and be mired in
negativity and anger and hatred or you
spend your time making something amazed
and building yourself up and getting
into new things with my website I get
ripped off all the time okay people rip
off my quotes they rip off my videos
they rip off my website they rip off my
content my copy and they'll rip it off
blatantly and put their name on it word
for word what I said and put their name
on it they're never going to have
success it's great to model you can
model what I'm doing and make it your
own and put your spin on it and make it
personal to you that can work but taking
what I do and word-for-word copying it
it's not going to work and I don't want
to waste my time on these people because
I have two options
I either spend my time making videos
like this answering your videos on on
YouTube on Twitter answering your
questions building new products building
new resources to help you guys out to
build the momentum and to build the
revolution of entrepreneurship I either
do that same I tell the things that
build me up build entrepreneurs up and
empower me excite me get me passionate
or I spend my time chasing these guys
down and I'm pissed off and I'm angry
all the time and what's it doing these
guys will never amount to anything
they're not worthy of my time and they
shouldn't be worthy of yours either I
got a question from a YouTube viewer
love you guys gonzo gonzo writes in long
email basically he's in the lawn care
business and he he has a whole series of
craigslist ads and Backpage ads and on
the website and his competitors are
ripping everything off and doing exactly
the same thing as him and he said he
spent some time
and following up with them and trying to
chase them down and sometime ignoring
them when he's pissed off from Houston
Texas
gonzo from Houston Texas wanted to know
what should he do
gonzo man these guys are not worthy of
your time let them do their thing
invest your time in the making your
business better be the best lawn care
company Houston Texans has ever seen and
the guys who just trying to copy you
word for word they're never going to
make it these guys are struggling to
survive man they're struggling and the
last thing they didn't think of their
last-ditch effort here is to rip you off
your best bet is just to ignore those
guys and keep building what you're doing
I've got an investment in a salsa
dancing company here in Toronto okay the
biggest salsa dancing school probably in
North America teach five six thousand
people a year how to dance salsa I
helped the company with their marketing
okay one of the things that I brought
and we create a great content and so for
example on our homepage you wrote a
great article maybe seven hundred words
a thousand words something like that a
new competitor popped up with almost the
exact same name same domain name just
with like an extra word on it and they
took the copy exactly from our home page
the exact copy word-for-word exact copy
put it on their home page and if you
typed in anything that was in that copy
and see our page and then you see
there's it's desperate you know it's so
desperate you know that these guys are
not business people they're struggling
they can't make ends meet they have no
idea what they're doing so the best
thing I can think of is a copy somebody
else word for word and you know what a
year later they're gone I don't even
know what happened to them their
websites gone these guys who are who are
coming after you gonzo man they're not
going to be around they're not real
business people running these things so
just keep your head down focus on
providing a great service ignore the
haters and as you get more successful
you're going to get more haters you're
going to get more people copying you
word-for-word more people ripping you
off
as I get more successful with my videos
and con
ten and all that there's more people
ripping me off there's somebody on
Facebook who said she was married to me
use my picture and like Photoshop me in
with her and we have this relationship
and it created a fake account for me and
saying that we were married it's like
what is happening I can only imagine it
getting it worse imagine imagine the
bigger players imagine look at people in
the entertainment industry look at look
at Justin Bieber okay how many people
use him as their Twitter profile or
impersonate him or try to put out tweets
as him try to put out content as him or
rip him off exactly word for word how
many people it's crazy as you get bigger
more people will rip you off okay think
of it as a form of flattery use it as a
way to make you work hard or come up
with something new something better so
that it's hard to replicate use it as
fuel to make your business better and
keep believing you're the leader man
everybody wants to be you own it believe
for those you're watching you like the
video give it a thumbs up below makes
want to do more for you and hey I want
to hear from you leave a comment
underneath let me know your thoughts you
have a question put it below your
thoughts and comments create the content
for these videos and they make my day
everyday when I'm eating my breakfast
watching the the your comments come in
so thank you so much leave a comment and
I'll see you soon